In this video I want to solve a few examples by looking at it
its distribution and its various characteristics,
such as crowds, gaps and peaks.
Here I want to solve some examples.
Which of the following are true descriptions?
of the distribution below?
Choose all the correct answers.
The first statement states that the distribution has a distant point.
A distant point is a data point that is a long distance
from where other data points are located.
It has a greater or lesser value and is at a distance
from where they are clustered
all other data points, and if we look at it here,
we have many points with data between 0 and 6.
Let's just think what they measure:
this is the shelf life of each apple
in the store of Gorg.
For example, we see that there are 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6, 7 apples that have a shelf life
0 days, so (laughter) they will spoil.
You see that you have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8 apples that will be fit for another day.
You have 2 apples that will be fit
another 6 days and you have an apple,
which will be ready for another 10 days, and this is unusual.
This is a remote point, it has a much higher score of fitness
of all other data, so I would say,
that we definitely have a remote point here.
We only have this data point,
which is so far to the right, much larger,
with a much longer shelf life than anything else, so the distribution definitely
there is a remote point and this will be the point.
Distribution is crowded in 4 to 6 days.
We really see crowding in 4 to 6 days.
The clustering, as you can imagine, is the grouping of data,
who are there or have apple groupings,
which have a shelf life between 4 and 6 days,
as you see that cluster there.
Since I have already chosen two things,
I definitely will not choose "None of the above".
I will check my answer.
Let's solve some of these tasks.
Which of the following are true descriptions?
of the distribution below?
We will choose all who are faithful.
The distribution has a distant point.
Let's look at this distribution.
I really have one point here that is finally
and I have one more here, which is at the beginning,
but I do not have any data points that are located
at a great distance above or below all data.
If I had a data point you are here, then yes,
I would say she is far to the right
or away from others if I had a point far left
on the screen here, maybe it would be a distant point.
But I really do not see any obvious distant point.
All the data is quite crowded in one place.
So I would not say that the distribution has a distant point.
The distribution has a peak at 22 degrees.
Yes, it really seems like there is -
let's just look at what we actually measure.
The height of the temperature every day in Eugarton, Iowa in July.
It really seems that we have the largest number
days in July that they had
temperature 22 degrees Celsius,
so it's a peak.
Imagine it was like a mountain,
this is the tip, the highest point.
You have, at least in this place, the greatest number of days
with 22 degrees Celsius.
So I would say we definitely have a peak there.
Since I chose something, I will not choose
None of the above.
Let's solve some of these tasks.
Which of the following are true descriptions?
of the distribution below?
The first is that the distribution has a distant point.
So, the number of visitors per day
in Seth's sandwich shop.
Let's see, at least ...
There are no days ...
There are no days in which he had between 0 and 19 visitors,
no days in which he had between 20 and 39 visitors,
it looks like there are about 9 days,
in which he had between 40 and 59 visitors,
it looks like about 20 days between 60 and 79 visitors.
It's up to where - it looks like maybe 8 days -
had between 180 and 199 visitors.
But the question of remote points - does not seem to exist
some day when he had an unusual number of visitors.
There is no day to be here,
in which, for example, there were 500 visitors.
So I would say that the distribution has no remote points.
The distribution has a crowd of 0 to 39 visitors.
So, from 0 to 39 visitors are right here.
There were no days in which he had between 0 and 39 visitors,
neither from 0 to 10 nor from 20 to 39.
So we definitely do not have a crowd there.
I would say that the crowding will be between the days,
which are between 40 and 199 visitors.
Definitely not at 0 and 30, there were no days,
which have from 0 to 39 visitors.
So I would say quite confidently - None of the above.
Let's solve one more of these tasks.
Which of the following are true descriptions?
of the distribution below?
(laughter) Okay.
The distribution has a peak of 12 to 13 points.
Let's see what is measured here for what this data is about.
Results of each student's test in Mrs. Freen's class.
There was 1 student who received between 0 and 1
20-point scale, so we have a ...
I suppose that out of 20 questions, he got between 0 and 1 point.
And then you see there are no students,
who received between 2 and 3 or 4 and 5 or 6 and 7 points.
Then we have another student who has received between 8 and 9,
it seems that 3 students received between 10 and 11,
and then continue to grow. It looks like around
12 students received 16 or 17,
or something between them maybe,
if you can get a fractional expression for the exam points.
And then it seems that 10 students have received from 18 to 19.
Well, here it says that the distribution has a peak
from 12 to 13 points.
There were 5 students there, but that's not the tip.
If you move to 14-15 points, you already have more students there.
So that's definitely not a peak.
If you look at this as some type of mountain,
you would definitely not describe this point as a peak.
You would say that the distribution has a peak,
there are the largest number of students,
who received between 16 and 17 points,
so that's where the top is, not 12 to 13 points.
So I will not choose the first answer.
The distribution has a distant point.
Well yes, look at this. You have this remote point.
Most students received between 8 and 19 points,
and then you have this one disciple,
which has received from 0 to 1, this really is a remote point.
You even see it clearly,
it is not even related to the rest of the distribution.
It is far left.
If something is far left or far to the right,
it is a distant point if it is unusually low or unusually high.
I would say that this distribution definitely
there is a remote point and I will not choose "None of the above"
since I found an answer.
I think we're done.